du premier anniversaire de cette
invasion russe on Ukraine et bien le
Premier ministre polonais matteus
moraviec s'est rendu à Kiev ce vendredi
en signe de soutien au pays l'assuré que
la Pologne allait envoyer plus de char
en Ukraine dans quelques jours alors
qu'elle vient d'ailleurs de livrer 4
chars léopard on va écouter tout de
suite à ce propos la réaction du
président
ukrainien veut le dire Zelinski
je vous remercie pour votre soutien
politique humanitaire
le soutien concret apporté aux
Ukrainiens koality
un des membres fondateurs de la
coalition des chars
aujourd'hui nous pouvons annoncer
l'arrivée des premiers chars depuis la
Pologne ceci est très important les
premiers chars qui arriveront seront des
chars polonais
Caroline de Camaret bonsoir vous êtes
spécialiste des questions européennes
pour France 24 la Pologne elle veut
apparaître depuis le début de l'invasion
russe depuis un an comme le plus fervent
soutien de Kiev est-ce que c'est c'est
vraiment le cas alors elle s'est en tout
cas dans le club européen elle est en
train de se racheter une virginité comme
on dit est-ce que vous avez vu ce
premier ministre polonais à Kiev qui
boit du petit lait parce que il a reçu
auparavant la visite de Joe Biden il va
livrer des chars il va livrer peut-être
des munitions dit-il qui vont être
fabriqués avec les Américains et ça
aussi c'est quelque chose dont il faut
parler et pourtant il est il était quand
même dans le club européen un petit peu
un mouton noir en matière d'état de
droit s'effon sont encore gelés par les
Européens parce qu'il y a une dérive sur
le système judiciaire bref il surfait
une virginité il a accueillie en effet
des millions de réfugiés sur son sol 5
millions qui sont qui ont traversé son
pays en effet et
et surtout effectivement aujourd'hui et
bien il y a vous le savez à l'heure où
on parle un Conseil européen pour
décider d'un dixième rang de sanctions
et là et bien il est en train de dire ah
ça n'est pas assez ce que l'on propose
sur les exportations de caoutchouc des
Russes n'est pas suffisant il faut aller
plus loin et Georgia Meloni Kia a besoin
du caoutchouc pour ses voitures
italiennes qui pourtant est dans le même
parti très très droitier donc les
conservateurs et réformistes européens
de Monsieur
moravieki en Pologne et bien ils sont en
train d'avoir des tensions fortes au
Conseil européen pour dire non on adopte
on adopte pas ce dixième plan de
sanction qui est important qui est mis
sur la table symboliquement le jour
anniversaire des un an et qui incluait
notamment des sanctions à leur pas sur
le gaz ça gênait pas pour une fois la
Hongrie parce que ça c'était c'est
normalement c'est l'empêcheur de tourner
en rond numéro 1 c'est quand même Victor
Hormann le premier ministre hongrois
mais ça gênait en tout cas un certain
nombre de personnalités dont des
propagandistes c'était la nouveauté
aussi de cette salle de sanction qui va
sans doute être adoptée ce soir quand
même l'Union européenne qui